well we talked earlier about what would
happen with Dan Quinn and I said I would
stick with him and Arthur black already
had made that decision in a video posted
online this morning
the announcement is made that both Dan
Quinn and Thomas dimitrov will return
next year and you can tell from the
video it was yesterday afternoon at the
latest when they shot this thing so this
decision has been made it wasn't just
something that Arthur blank rolled out
of bed this morning in deciding to do
he's sticking with Dan Quinn Quinn is
turned it around
dimitrov sticks around I think it's the
right move under the circumstances
simply because I don't know that they
would have found a significant upgrade
and chances are that Arthur blank looked
around to see what was out there before
he made this decision it's exactly what
we talked about it's the analysis we
discussed a half hour ago
and it just broke in the last 15 minutes
that's exactly what the Falcons are
doing yeah well there's a lot of things
to be positive about I mean one the team
continued to fight and play hard under
Dan Quinn I mean Thomas Dimitrov yeah we
talked about that too he's he's built a
team with a lot of high-end talent the
problem is depth a little bit they've
had the injury bug all of that so yeah I
understand it Arthur Blank he probably
wants to capitalize on what he's got
here and he's still in a big window with
Matt Ryan and Julio Jones
they just got some young offensive
linemen this year in this past draft so
they're a team that's not far off
they're really not it's just about a
little bit of a depth issue they can't
go another year of okay we've had three
or four injuries and we get decimated
and then all of a sudden we can't even
be competitive for four or five weeks
until we figure out the new formula
that's the only indictment on Dimitrov
and Quinn the last two years it's the
only thing
Quinn not being able to coach that
Dimitrov maybe not giving enough depth
there the too big of a talent gap
between starters and backups but there's
been a lot of positives in their era for
sure also Raheem Morris the former head
coach the Tampa Bay Buccaneers will be
the new defensive coordinator remember
Laura Haim retained those duties so
Raheem stepping up he'd pin the
receivers coach entering the season now
he's gonna be the defense coordinator
next year maybe he's laying the
foundation to be a head coach somewhere
else in 2021
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports